let's jump into this first story so as
we're getting ready to uh put the show
together we i caught this story it was
published just around 6 p.m fbi delivers
subpoenas to several pa republican
lawmakers sources say
at least some of the individuals
receiving subpoenas were told they were
not targets of an investigation
according to at least six sources
reached by penlive but that they may
have information of interest to the fbi
all of the sources have been briefed on
the investigative moves in some way but
demanded anonymity in order to discuss
them the information being requested
centered around u.s rep scott perry and
the efforts to seek alternate electors
as part of former president donald
trump's efforts to remain in office
after the 2020 election several sources
say said the washington post on
wednesday citing a source for me with
the probe also reported that perry's
cell phone was seized tuesday as part of
the justice department's criminal
investigation into the use of fake
electors to try to overturn president
biden's victory the post source also
spoke on the condition of anonymity
spokespersons for the pennsylvania house
and senate republican leaders did not
confirm whether any of their caucus
members received a subpoena quote i am
unaware of any fbi presence in the
capital or leader benninghoff's office
yesterday to the extent house members or
my staff may have contact may have been
contact contacted by the fbi we would
not comment on a potential or ongoing
investigation
so
there's a there's a few simple points to
make and the first one i'm going to say
is i don't trust the fbi i don't trust
the doj i don't trust the federal
government
that being said
they're they're trying to claim
that by having alternate electors it's
some kind of fraud but if you go back to
i think it was 1968 correct with my
wrong during it was nixon and kennedy
was it was it 68 maybe i'm wrong i don't
know you want to check me
there was a dispute in hawaii
and hawaii sent an alternate slate of
electors which nixon as the vice
president decided to use even though
they weren't the certified electors
what's in 1960 next 60 nixon kennedy
yeah and next okay so 60. yeah why did i
68. um
now what happens is you have this uh
contentious legal battle in 2020 a bunch
of republicans
you know the the electors for the
republican side which were not the
certified electors for the state did
fill out these forms and sentiment
anyway now they're acting as though that
was a criminal action or fraud or
something perhaps they're going to use
that as a means to stop donald trump
from being from being able to run again
or it's just part of the bigger just go
after trump by all means or whatever do
you think this is similar to the nevada
they called them fake electors but
alternate electors that were subpoenaed
by the general six committee yeah it's
all the same thing
this is so interesting to me because it
just looks like the media is writing
history in real time like they want us
to believe this is insane it's never
happened before but it happened in 1960
there's nothing crazy about this they're
just trying to make it up as they go
along i do think the whole thing's crazy
it's a little weird yeah so we had i
think it was 46 states or something that
were involved in a lawsuit do you
remember this in uh in 2020
the texas filed a lawsuit against i
think pennsylvania maybe pennsylvania
and then it expanded into like 46 states
where you had like 24 suing 20 you know
assuming these these like it was
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania and then
you had the other 22 in defense of those
states
and the supreme court which has original
jurisdiction to hear lawsuits between
states rejected it they said no outright
so we never got resolution on these
arguments and this is leading
now
we're heading to the point where the fbi
has raided the home of the former
president right told them their lawyer
could not be present while they were
enacting the search
broke the padlock off the room that they
requested be there god i got an
interesting email earlier
and i'll call it unconfirmed
in my morning segment i was talking
about there's a report from uh ken i
think it's kendallene i could be wrong
he was on nbc
and he said a few months ago the fbi
requested a padlock be placed on this
room at mar-a-lago which had these
documents
they then went in and broke the padlock
they requested
that's a simple way to put it if you
think the fbi is one guy
but the fbi is not one guy it's not a
monolith right so i got contacted by
someone alleging that they were
a former uh fbi agent and they said
you know
they didn't tell me anything crazy they
just said you're right the fbi is a
bunch of different offices it's not
monolithic there is leadership but often
they're
you know there's like senior leadership
that will take actions in one direction
without one other office knowing so my
assessment was
one group of on the on the board on the
level fbi agents say okay we know what
you got here it's fine just padlock it
in case
this other group of agents gets a
warrant signed off by an epstein judge a
former epstein uh defense attorney
yeah and then goes in and smashes the
padlock and sees his documents or
something like that allegedly
yeah so uh banana republic collapse
united states um i'll throw it to my
panel
one of the most wild things i read
coming out of all of that was andrew
cuomo who's like the doj should really
explain what's going on otherwise it's
going to start to look like the january
6 committee is not credible
andrew cuomo the disgraced ex-governor
of new york i mean if anyone really can
recognize when something is corrupt i
like i would assume someone who has been
asked to leave office would be a good
good judge of character there yeah i i
mean
should i just jump right in and yeah
what do you think right yeah
you know when i was a political
consultant um to the vice president in
2000 also a contested election outcome
in which no one was criminalized for
asking questions about the outcome i
mean this is really haunting me but also
i advised um the clinton re-election
campaign and what i learned as a
political consultant is to read events
backwards in other words what's
happening like what's the what's the
outcome like let's leave the story alone
because what you learn
as a consultant is that at that level
the guys in the room choose the outcome
and
and then they go to the message guys
down the hall and ask the message guys
to come up with a story to get the
american people to accept the outcome
the goal and often the story has nothing
to do with the goal so i'd encourage you
almost like don't pay that much
attention to what you're being told
about the reasons that lawmakers who are
republican are being subpoenaed or that
the president of the united states has
you know 30
people bursting into his private home
and seizing his materials and look at
everyone else project veritas is related
to this steve bannon having a swat team
going into his private home is related
to this i mean what the you know leaving
the stories aside the overall chess
board is the criminalization of being a
republican
you know and do you ever think you'd say
that
i mean yeah i wrote this book the end of
america in 2008 warning that we were
hurtling toward you know that there are
10 steps tyrants always take to close
down an open society and that step 10 is
where we're at now i didn't know we'd
get here so fast i thought we'd headed
off at the pass because we're you know
able to cherish our republic but clearly
we're not doing that but yeah so the the
outcome is you're exactly right to worry
about timing tim because
you know these are dangerous months and
i've been saying this for months you
know leading up to these months you what
what are we in now uh august september
october november right it's going to get
crazy and the goal is to have things so
unstable so scary
chilling everywhere you know shocking
images people's homes being broken open
people being led away in handcuffs peter
navarro in leg chains right this is all
part of the the drama the spectacle of
what what other countries like like
russia and china understand is
tenderizing an enemy so the american
people are being tenderized right now
and the goal is to completely
incapacitate the republican leadership
to scare journalists and critics like
you and me because that's part of it and
i'll just say me i'm scared
and and also to um to tie up the
leadership like bannon and trump in so
many legal problems and hassles that
they are not able to uh to pose a threat
to the outcomes that are already foreign
and alex jones and alex jones absolutely
he's not you know jones was so massively
influential in 2014-1516
they they
they found a way to get him off all
these platforms and alex jones for all
the criticisms that i think he deserves
he got wiped off of the internet back to
back all the same time right you know so
so maybe you can call it a cascade
effect but i think
powerful interests were like this is a
guy who's rallying people with a massive
platform this can't be allowed right
i guess i guess my question for you when
you wrote the book in 2008 did you think
it was going to be republicans who would
turn out to be the victims of this
that's such a painful question
i mean right right at the time um it was
republicans doing the bad things as mitt
romney and like john mccain
oh no worse it was dick cheney i mean it
was guantanamo it was you know the
global war on terror that was the
terrifying internal external threat
invocation that's step one of the ten
steps to fascism now it's a virus um
but
to be fair liz cheney's still here and
she's leading the charge yeah you know
well thank goodness
wyoming is so happy
i i guess what i said then i mean i
remember this my my people are so dumb
um
who are your people in this the former
liberal i mean i'm a i'm a liberal by
you know classical liberal all my life
registered democrat all my life
my former people my former tribe of the
left are
very short-sighted and they're they're
cheering about you know project veritas
is in trouble donald trump is in trouble
it's like cheering the rope that is
going to hang them metaphorically you
know and they're not reading history but
the reason i say this is that in 2008 i
remember everyone around me going we
just need to get obama in and then there
will be no more tyranny and i'm like are
you insane are you insane these things
of you know shutting down democracies
the left and the right both do it and
and during the obama years i was one of
like
five people on the left including glenn
greenwald who were like you know what
he's drowning americans guantanamo is
still open it's growing you know all of
these promises are not being kept um so
i didn't expect it would be republicans
being hunted but i'm not surprised that
that has come about i was fairly young
in 2008 i voted for obama and
i was skeptical but i kept hearing from
all these people saying like this guy's
different he's not the same part of the
machine he's an outsider and you know he
came from community organizing and i was
like i don't know sure whatever i'll
vote for the guy and then one of the
first things he did was he blew up some
kids right was uh i think it was like
literally within a few days a drone
strike in pakistan killed a killer wipe
hit a village and then i was like wait a
minute we were protesting the war and
this guy just did this thing
then when 2012 came around i was just
like yeah right you're not going to get
me to vote for this guy again
and now we've got uh i i love bringing
it up because of how important it is the
the extrajudicial assassinations carried
out by the obama administration this is
why i was so adamantly opposed to joe
biden i ended up voting for trump i
didn't vote for him in 2016 but in 2020
i was like you're not giving me biden
you know obama 2.0 or whatever and and
it ended up ended up happening so
well you've had quite a journey i mean
how do people your former friends feel
about that
former friends right you know uh well
interestingly my real friends that i
mostly grew up with only a few of them
have lost their minds but there have
been some weird circumstances but
surprisingly like i have a friend who's
deeply woke
still a really good friend and just like
we don't talk about it yeah it's it's
kind of weird and it comes up sometimes
and you can feel tensions rising and
then it's just like let's talk about
horror movies
but i'm glad that can happen yeah but
but i do think
you know for for someone like this a
friend of mine they're not overtly
political it's you know you're
mentioning the your former liberal you
know associates or cohorts or whatever
they're just not paying attention and
they're passively absorbing what they're
being told and assuming it's true yeah
i can't yeah i should say i feel like
with my friends
liberal or even there are conservatives
like this too they're
a lot of them aren't inherently
political and there are a couple issues
that matter to them and so they'll buy
the whole ticket even though they can't
see like you're saying that these are
ultimately interwoven issues they can't
see
what their decisions will lead to in the
domino effect i gotta just jump right to
abortion
right uh the democrats recently tried to
pass a bill that would that would allow
abortion up to nine months oh god it
didn't it so it was cleverly worded
that um
in the instance where the mother's
health was in jeopardy an abortion could
be carried out post a viability right
and so i my my response we had a
progressive on was very simple like okay
i hear you if the baby is viable why
abort it yeah why not just deliver it
did this person actually support
that bill and and and beyond this
individual told us it's the woman's
choice no matter what up to the point of
birth yeah and my position insane i grew
up in chicago i grew up with a liberal
family and we were always like yeah
maybe like the first trimester
pre-viability we understand after that
you're you're in dangerous territory now
the left is just wholesale like whenever
whatever i think larry elder was on the
show and saying that it's uh the health
of the mother as well so it could be
like if she's gonna suffer depression
then maybe she can terminate an eight
and a half month old fetus
it's not just about the life of the
mother it's about the health of the
mother which is like vague but
just to bring it up you know you as uh i
guess former you could you consider
yourself a former liberal you're still
liberal no i'm i'm a classical liberal i
you know me and three other people yeah
yeah or politically homeless as you know
yes totally a political refugee
absolutely so so you're obviously not in
favor of abortion up to nine months no i
am not yeah it's it's crazy what the
left has become
that they would call us right-wing
you're raising questions about that it's
crazy it's insane i mean what really
scares me about this is the kind what
i'm seeing on the left
is this kind of um entrainment almost
intellectually where if
the thing is support ukraine you can't
ask any questions about you know
ukraine's abusiveness to the rule of law
if the thing is abortion
and under any circumstances no matter
how crazy the bill is no matter how
extreme how sadistic how abusive how i
would say anti-woman and anti-baby it is
to you know extend the abortion
capability into the second month into
the i'm sorry second trimester third
trimester
if that's the thing
it just seems to be plugged into
people's minds on the right and they
just kind of follow like lemmings like
with no critical thinking they can't
demur
and there are a lot of interesting
reasons for that but i do think on the
left um critical debate is no longer
possible and
and it's so important to distinguish
themselves from
from like trump lovers or whatever they
call anyone who disagrees with them um
and and that's really scary to me
because if you look at history it's
people in that mind state that go along
with genocide and look what they went
along with and go along with the former
left people i know and love who would
never discriminate against a gay couple
or lesbian couple never discriminate on
the basis of race embraced a
discrimination society that was just
like a jim crow two-tier
discrimination society thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there
you